yes get some New Vegas golden knights
gear put that on your to-do list a
t-shirt yeah a chance doll maybe a big
necklace Lauren negretti has pretty much
everything you could ever imagine all
she's got the Sparkles yes girl you got
the Sparkles all right you're at that
Las Vegas South Premium Outlets uh do
they have anything left for sale
yeah there's still some stuff no you
know when I Heather you told me when I
moved here I needed more sequins in my
life well girl we got it here right here
at Vegas sports and hockey here I'm
joined by Bruce manecki owner of this
whole glorious store you got two
locations actually and so okay what are
some most popular items taking a stroll
down your uh your style your aisle here
well we've got items from drinkware we
got hockey pucks we've got swimsuits
we've got tank tops
um beanie hats regular hats we've got
something for every age group from the
newborns all the way to the big sizes so
we can supply any of you people with
Vegas Knights items something for
everyone from all Scopes here okay and
so as far as you know the trend you've
been seeing items just flying off the
shelf here how's it been going and how
do you kind of expect it to go uh come
Saturday well the last two weeks we've
been building and building and building
and now that we finally made it to the
Stanley Cup for the second time we're
gonna see the Western Conference Final
items this week that'll just blow up off
the shelves in time for the the game on
Saturday I think everyone is going to
want a New Jersey to get involved with
the game we've got hats that we'll have
in different sizes and selection all
week we'll have new items coming in
everything in the store is gonna just
really explode for all the people to
support our local team
you can shop local while you're thank
you so much well stay with us here more
stuff I'll find more stuff at this point
just Heather tell me what you want to
see just right here at the Vegas hockey
Sports and hockey store right here hit
the nail on the head with the glitter
that is for sure sequins and glitter and
Lauren I think Bruce is just like the
golden knights he's all business this
morning he's like I got some stuff but
you know we're focused on the bottom
line here they're they're looking to the
Stanley Cup Lauren and I are looking to
sequins and chance dolls